in our morning rounds the alarming rise
in childhood diabetes type 2 diabetes
was once known as adult onset because it
was so rare in kids but not anymore
with one in five school-age children
considered obese the rate of type two
diabetes and young people is climbing
the newest study shows almost five
percent jump over a decade for those
between the ages of 10 and 19 some
experts warn the number is still rising
our doctor Tara Narula is here with the
dangers of the disease at every age
doctor good morning good morning why are
we seeing such a sharp rise this is not
something we talked about 20 years ago
and it is heartbreaking to think that
now in this country there are about
20,000 children children who have type 2
diabetes 5,000 new cases a year and this
is a disease that is going to take a
physical emotional and an economic toll
on these individuals so how did we get
here one of the biggest risk factors is
obesity we have an obesity epidemic in
addition to that look at the lifestyle
we lead now how many of our children are
getting the recommended 60 minutes of
exercise how many are sitting in front
of screens all day long eating fast and
processed food in addition there's a
family history component so as our
society we are all having more diabetes
as adults we potentially can pass that
on to our children either genetics
environmental exposure and then what
happened prenatally the more women have
gestational diabetes the more their kids
are at risk for developing type 2
diabetes do you treat children
differently than you treat adults who
have type 2 diabetes what I used to know
is adult onset diabetes right so they we
what we're learning is that we need a
lot more research about this we do not
have enough research to know how to
appropriately treat children we're
basing a lot of it on adults and what we
do for adults but for example we have a
lot of medications that we can use for
adults for kids we can only use two so
far that are considered safe and
approved by the FDA metformin and
insulin we also have to engage kids at a
level that may be different from adults
we have to not talk down and preach to
them we have to educate them and empower
them we have to use things that kids
like to use like technology to bring
them into learning about diabetes
education we have to make our messaging
culturally appropriate because there are
racial and ethnic differences in how
this disease affects kids so you know
there are differences for
sure is it passed from generation to
generation it can be so there's
definitely a family history component do
you think parents should be held
accountable because most kids aren't
cooking for themselves they're not
exercising on their own not at five
years old which is we can see this as
early as that so certainly parents are
part of the issue and they need to be
part of the solution you have to engage
the whole family in the process of
dealing with this to teach them how to
eat healthy and exercise because
lifestyle is part of it but the
complications and I think that's what
people don't really think about with
this disease we see the complications
not when kids are 50 or 60 we're seeing
this as early as five or ten years down
the road when kids are now in the prime
of their lives they're starting jobs
they're in college they're having
families and what's happening to them
and they're developing end-stage renal
disease leading them to dialysis heart
attack and stroke and a neuropathy big
big problems that can retinopathy
blindness so very important no wake up
call thank you yes sure you find out if
you've got it get the tests thank you
very much dr. Terry no rule